hey guys this is andrew from
chainsenses.com so i've been working as
a professional trainer for the past six
years in hong kong and right now i'm
doing
youtube videos because guys i wanna
actually show you how projectors are
working i'm pretty sure that if you're
here
it's because you have questions you are
wondering how we make money on the
markets are some people really making
money
and if they do how do they do i can tell
you that yes some people really make
money
it's not easy if you work as a
professional you have a team
it's easier than being on your own but
you're not on your own guys i'm here and
i'm gonna
do my best to actually show you what is
working for me
so today i'm gonna make a video update
on the bitcoin
let's get into it
[Music]
so everybody's asking me please do one
on the bitcoin please the one on the
bitcoin so here we
are very interesting what we're having
so let me first
go on the shorter time frame the fourth
time frame is nice on the bitcoin
so i was saying guys you know for those
who watched my previous videos
that 35 was my first resistance level
then 55
and we went to 58 how did i find that
i use fib extension so i measured the
previous move
so let me show you quickly how i find
that then i'm going to show you
so here you have a lot of information
guys
don't worry i'm gonna explain everything
so to find
the 35 and 55 i just measured uh the
previous wave which is here
and i applied to the bottom of my false
wave and this is giving me
my levels that were here so those are my
levels but it's funny that it's not only
mine it's funny that actually
you have as always sega's selling
pressures at those levels here we have
this consolidation at the 1.618
and the next one so i follow those those
levels guys fib extension ratios
uh ratios of the golden number thirty
five thousand fifty five thousand
and it's funny to see that thirty five
thousand we had some consolidation and
fifty
eight thousand all right it's not very
precise but you know we had this
rejection
and here we have this consolidation
again so let me get rid of this
so we see more clearly now the question
we have is are we gonna go to the next
one which is around 75 thousand
so ultimately yes i think so but
how so to answer this question i need to
make some illiot wave counting so idiot
wave is actually
a principle developed in the 30s by
ralph ellison elliot
this guy's a genius and he understood a
lot of
dynamics in the market in the investor
psychology and he used this
to actually make some rules that you can
use
to predict uh market movements sounds
easy
it's not uh and for those who want to
know more please click on the link in
the description of the video and you're
going to receive a free video
uh where i explain everything about
idiot with some theory
and some practice so here first thing is
that
like i said uh i think i think that
this was a force all right and that we
are now doing the fifth wave all right
of the
whole move up so i can show you this
quickly again
here right uh so i do
i try to find five waves and here it's
working very well one two three four
five
abc abc ah zigzag flat
okay so it looks perfect and each time i
can break down the moves in five waves
with the third wave being the strongest
one
so now this is our fifth wave so the
question is where is it going
my answer is around three hundred
thousand but let's go step by step
before we reach three hundred thousand a
lot of things are gonna happen and you
can get
wiped out very easily